okay guys so to wrap this video up i
really don't think this cursed episode
of this show was real it's obviously
just a really good scary fan animation
and the fact that the creators behind it
didn't come out and claim ownership of
it sooner allowing it to be reposted and
re-uploaded so many times is really what
got people thinking was legit that being
said it's still a good attempt at what a
cursed lost episode would look like so
shout out to those animators man anyway
i've been the goat hellholder98 be sure
to like this video subscribe to my
channel down below and hey if you know
about any more lost media you want me to
cover leave it in the comments i'll
check it out and be sure to follow my
socials at hellholder98 i go live most
days and post updates about new videos
on my story so go check it out alright
until then i'll see you somewhere down
the line the moment his finger pushed
the button to stop the camera recording
the practiced false smile dropped from
holden's face it was hard not to feel
down after he'd finished filming a new
video not thanks to any post-creativity
slump but the more depressing knowledge
of just how much of an uphill battle
this whole thing was it felt like
yesterday when holden had first gotten
into the creepier side of the internet
he never ventured into anything illicit
or outright illegal mind you but there
was a distinct corner of the web that
had pulled him in when he was still at
school and just starting to spend more
time online this part of the internet
was filled with scary stories that were
mostly fake or made up for likes but
that could have been real there were
unsettling animations short clips that
were hand drawn to give people the
creeps and keep them up at night not to
mention a whole archive of public safety
announcement videos terrifying workplace
and road safety warnings that used to be
broadcast on tv and were as petrifying
than the most acclaimed horror movies
speaking of things that were broadcast
to tv that had gradually become holden's
specialty one of his friends had sent
him the link to a fictional account of
someone who had supposedly uncovered an
unaired episode of a saturday morning
kids cartoon or so this person claimed
anyway they went on to describe bizarre
imagery so intense and terrifying that
it was unbefitting of a show for
children then the person who made the
original post explained how they got
into contact with the show's creators
via email to ask them about this cursed
episode the showrunner responded stating
that the episode the poster had
allegedly seen
didn't even exist to holden it didn't
matter if the story was real or not that
wasn't the point what was far more
important was that it felt real to him
it was plausible even possible that
there were pieces of media out there in
the world that had never seen the light
of day episodes of tv shows or entire
movies that were so wild and out there
that they could have been banned and
buried long before the dawn of the
internet wherein there was a record of
everything and nothing was ever really
lost the idea of uncovering those lost
pieces of media became holden's primary
hobby he'd come home from school throw
his backpack onto his bed and then sit
in front of his computer for hours
without even changing out of the clothes
he had been wearing all day in class but
all the time he spent trawling through
forum threads following and messaging
collectors on social media listening to
theories and coming up with his own
eventually it began to encroach on other
things much to his mom's disappointment
holden's grades took a rapid decline it
wasn't long before he was failing his
classes bad enough to not make the cut
to continue on at school but as much as
it upset his mother holden really didn't
mind he was already thinking way beyond
high school and he knew he didn't need
grades to be able to do the one thing he
wanted to do with his life holden set up
his own channel with the plan to start
uploading videos under his new online
alter ego and before long hellholder98
was born he centered his whole internet
persona around lost media discussing
which popular rumors were true and which
were fictionalized for likes and clicks
it started out with a few discussion
videos where he would simply sit in his
bedroom a camcorder opposite him as he
spoke but before long holden was adding
more and more flair to his content
learning how to edit on his computer
adding clips or screenshots he could
find of supposed lost tv episodes to
give his videos some credibility a very
necessary quality when trying to
determine if certain things were real or
not each video he finished he added
another two topics to a list of ideas he
kept planning to just perpetually churn
out content until he eventually had a
huge hit that went viral although the
one thing he didn't realize until it was
perhaps too late was that social media
success didn't happen overnight in fact
it didn't happen over many many nights
either no matter how often holden
promoted his channel on his social media
profiles or how many new videos he
uploaded he couldn't seem to get any to
land well and get boosted by the
algorithm at least that's one of the
things he attributed the problem to he
pointed the finger of blame at anything
that he could one day it was that the
algorithm was suppressing his channel
and boosting others who had already got
more subscribers the next it might be
his slow internet connection had led to
one of his videos going live at a time
when the site had low traffic the one
possibility that holden didn't stop to
consider was that maybe his genre of
content was too niche but that the days
of the internet's interest in lost media
had already peaked back when he was
still in high school nevertheless he
kept trying making content day in and
day out working under the assumption
that if he just made enough videos then
one day he was sure to blow up that
would be his big break his ultimate win
a video that did well enough to garner
thousands if not millions of views but
the more time he devoted to hellholder98
the only number that seemed to be at all
increasing was the number of videos he
had posted each one barely garnering
view figures that were above a single
digit to make matters worse getting help
with growing his online brand was next
to impossible every now and then he
would post on forums asking for advice
or if anyone wanted to collaborate so he
could gain some exposure from creators
with bigger followings those posts were
often met with a slew of apathetic snide
responses or comments telling holden to
just quote make better content as if
that was solid specific advice on top of
that his mom had outright refused to
support her son's chosen career path
citing his failure at school as the main
reason speaking of any friends holden
previously had at school had all moved
away in the years since going off to
pursue college and other higher
education some were even starting their
new and exciting professions the old
saying said it's lonely at the top but
holden was just as lonely down at the
bottom posting his content in total
obscurity as if he was just shouting
into an empty void with no one around to
hear the few people holden did still
consider his friends were all as
chronically online as he was most of
them fellow lost media collectors after
interacting with them in the common
threads of various forums the handful of
like-minded guys were as close as holden
had to people actively supporting his
channel the collectors would usually
give him pointers or topics to discuss
in videos and contributing to the
single-digit view count underneath his
uploads although to him it wasn't nearly
enough he didn't want just his friends
to see his videos he wanted an audience
a fan base of his own it was late the
light of the computer monitor
illuminating the dark of holden's
bedroom hunched over his desk he was
clicking and dragging clips into the
timeline of a video project trimming
them down to make the whole thing better
paced snipping out bad takes where he
stumbled over his words or misspoke it
was while editing that holden noticed
another screen lighting up on his desk
accompanied by a vibration his phone he
reached for it seeing a notification
popped up on the lock screen it was from
goth one of the lost media collectors
and it read dude urgent found something
that you can make a video on hold inside
it was late and he was already focused
on editing this current video tonight if
he got it finished then he could go to
sleep what do you know about the deathly
videotape goth asked in a second message
before holden even had a chance to open
it first the what he replied bluntly
before sending another text saying can't
this wait until the morning i'm trying
to edit if you don't act fast it'll be
gone forever came the response only a
second later followed by a link
lethargically holden tapped the
hyperlink ghost had sent his phone
opening up its browser and displaying
the web page it was a buy and sell
website one of those places where people
offloaded junk they didn't want any more
to strangers for a bit of extra cash the
page in question showed a few grainy
photos taken on a phone of a small
rectangular object in someone's hand
what is that holden asked it's a
videotaped bonehead both fired back
although they'd never met in person
holden always got the sense his friend
was a little older than he was looking
back on the seller's ad it was for a
secondhand sony color collection 60 to
90 minute mini dv videotape a type of
cassette used in a lot of old handheld
recording cameras so what holden asked
in another text look there have been
rumors for aegis about something called
the deathly videotape goth replied in a
series of rapid fire messages it used to
be all the rage on a lot of old lost
media forums the real nasty ones before
they got shut down supposedly there's a
recording on this tape of some kind of
live show except when you put in your
vcr and press play you see something
horrible nobody even knows if it's real
or just a legend how do you know this is
the same tape holden queried by now he
had typed out the same link on his
computer and was looking at the for sale
page on the bigger screen while he
texted back and forth with both read the
item description he answered holden's
eyes scanned down the page finding a
short message from the seller to anyone
interested i'm giving this old mini dv
tape away i don't know where i got it or
why i watched it but i wish i hadn't it
had ruined everything for me it's
impossible to enjoy anything else now
that i've seen what's on it let me make
this clear i am not selling this tape
i'm giving it away free of charge i hope
that getting rid of it will help sounds
ominous holden texted if you're so sure
if this is the deathly videotape then
why don't you get it keep reading goth
responded underneath the item
description was another note that the
seller had written please note i am
unable to leave my town at present nor
can i mail this tape to anyone even if
you pay postage collection only if
you're interested please contact me at
the following address below was an
address it was in holden's hometown only
a few streets away from where he and his
mom lived this could be it dude came
another slew of messages from ghost you
buy this tape and make a video recording
then you might finally go viral but you
better be quick before someone goes and
picks it up thinking it's just an
ordinary tape holden looks back at the
address double checking where it was at
most it'd take a quick walk there and
back he thought and if this tape was as
elusive as goth said it was then owning
it would mean holden would be the only
one who could make a video featuring it
after messaging the seller the night
before holden found himself rushing
through his quiet neighborhood to the
address all night as he tried to sleep
he kept thinking of the video he was
going to make how he could finally put
him on the map and at long last bring
him the e-fame he'd been working towards
wrapping his knuckles against the front
door he was met by an older man who
stood on the other side he was walking
with a crutch with a few bruises and
stitched up cuts on his face the second
that holden explained he was there for
the tape the man reached to an unseen
shelf just inside the door frame and
thrust the rectangular cassette into his
hands before shutting the door as
quickly as he could without it hitting
holden square in the face he stared at
the tape in his hands though through its
transparent green plastic case he could
see a hand-scrawled note i know you'll
ignore me if i tell you not to watch
this it read so if you do then on your
own head be it having spent the rest of
the day looking up exactly what he'd
need to play such an old outmoded
recording format and convert the footage
to digital so he could include it in his
video holden had retrieved his mom's old
vhs player from the attic wiping the
thick layer of dust off of it it took a
while for him to get everything ready to
go not just finding the right adapters
and cables to hook the vcr up to his tv
as well as linking that to his computer
plus angling his camera right and making
sure the ring light he'd bought for
filming was putting enough focus on his
face after the substantial prep holden
took a deep breath summoning up the faux
excitement and staged smile before he
hit the record button on his camera
what's up guys it's hellholder98 here
now today i've got a real treat for you
all so my friend goth shout out to him
told me that a while ago there was talk
about something called the deathly
videotape we found a mini dv tape that
we think might be that very same tape so
we're going to watch it and see if it's
legit dropping his persona as his face
turned away from the camera hold and
punch the play button on the vhs player
his eyes glued to the tv screen as the
camera's lens was fixated on him okay
nothing so far he observed met with
nothing but a blank black screen
suddenly after 12 seconds of nothing the
playback started instantly and holden
started relaying what he was seeing on
the tape to the camera there was no
sound either because the recording on
the videotape was filmed that way or
holden hadn't properly figured out how
to hook it up to the vhs the video
itself showed a recording of sesame
street live and for the most part just
seemed pretty underwhelming characters
were up on stage their puppeteers
managing to stay out of sight as they
entertained their young audience after
two and a half minutes holden was
starting to feel like he'd gone to all
this effort over what seemed to just be
someone's old unwanted home video just
as he was considering turning off the
camera and throwing the videotape in the
trash at almost the three minute mark
something weird started happening on the
stage the actor playing one of the
bigger characters seemed to be having
some trouble instantly trying to pull
off his cumbersome costume much to the
distress of the kids in the audience
looking on in horror but it wasn't just
the illusion that had been broken the
actor was trying to get out of his
costume because he was choking he
dropped to his knees on stage clawing at
his own throat before finally falling
face down totally still
asphyxiated dead over the next almost 20
seconds the same thing started happening
to another three of the characters on
stage all of them violently choking
while the children in the audience
screamed and cried silently on the
inaudible tape then at three and a half
minutes the video cut out holden was
unsure how to react at first a little
creeped out only to be somewhat bemused
he played it down for the camera
remarking that the video seemed tame
compared to some of the more graphic
fake content he'd seen but the whole
time even after wrapping recording
sitting awake all night to edit his
reaction video blurring out the parts
that would break the terms of service he
had no idea what he'd seen was actually
real or not finishing the final edit
just as the sun was coming up holden hit
upload and crawled into bed while his
video was uploaded the buzz of a text
message from goth awoke him dude i told
you this video was going to make it big
without even replying holden booted up
his computer and opened the page for his
newly uploaded video the view count was
already in the thousands and climbing
comments pouring in underneath mostly
from people debating whether or not the
contents of the tape had been faked
holden punched the air and excitement
he'd finally done it but as the video
kept playing he heard a wretching sound
coming from the computer's speakers he
turned to look back at his earlier self
filmed only the night before except what
he was seeing play out on screen now
wasn't what he remembered happening last
night it couldn't have because the
holden in that video was choking that
wasn't possible he was alive and
watching his own video right now but
somehow the footage was shown him dying
his airway blocked face turning red then
blue as tears streamed down his cheeks
in the video hellholder98 fell down dead
from asphyxiation and watching it made
holden feel sick to make matters worse
none of the comments under the video
seem to have witnessed the same ending
holden even texts goth to ask if the
same thing had happened but he described
the ending exactly as holden remembered
filming it but afterwards it didn't stop
happening everything he watched ended
the same every clip online every tv show
every movie holden couldn't even read a
book without some characters fictional
or otherwise keeling over and choking to
death just like the characters on the
tape he barely had time to acknowledge
the hits his reaction to the deathly
videotape were getting he was too busy
trying to figure out why he couldn't
stop seeing people dying the exact same
way even himself when he watched back
his old hellholder98 videos reacting to
the deathly videotape garnered a
respectable 3 million views but
hellholder98 never uploaded again
afterwards his channel went silent
remembered only as a one-hit wonder
until the video and the entire channel
were taken down holden was never
reported missing the foundation made
sure of that when they came by to
collect
scp-583 and place the videotape into
containment now if you're still in the
mood for some lost media that you might
not want to watch alone then you should
go and check out scp-1733
season opener or if you like your tv
game shows to be a little too real and a
lot deadlier why not grab the remote and
hit play on
scp-024 the announcer